it's not me I'm not imagining it we're
out here every night this for some
reason it's a little chilly in here
tonight but don't worry they're turning
up the heat
all I have to do is pull this lever and
hot coco will come out of the ceiling
scalding everybody in the audience
horribly I'll do that soon yeah it's
nice
well I gotta mention this this week at
the Macworld convention but you nerds
are excited huh
hey guys he just mentioned the Macworld
convention secrete oils why did I say
that anyway this week at the big Mack
World convention Apple computers
unveiled its Apple iPhone everybody's
talking about this thing there it is is
the Apple iPhone looks pretty amazing
apparently this phone is just incredibly
versatile even though it won't go on
sale until June Apple has already put
out a commercial that highlights some of
the iPhones features this commercials
everywhere it shows you everything the
iPhone does it's pretty cool commercial
take a look your life doesn't have room
for anymore devices
introducing the revolutionary new iPhone
from Apple it's here to set you free
it's a camera it's a movie player remote
control a bottle opener electric razor
blow dryer a mousetrap lip gloss a
condiment dispenser me a cheese grater
sonograms treadmill
the children's thermometer portable
shower bookmarks hand grenade
a pantry
[Music]
get sideburns and it's a prophylactic
[Music]
it's also a heart to use cell phones the
iPhone it's everything it was great when
the guy got sprayed with mace Oh some
good acting there is that true Lemmy oh
yeah it was great yeah look like a mouse
batting at some cheese Who am I to make
fun I'm an ass